go back to the most painful or
emotionally challenging moment you had
as a boy what would you say to that boy
now to help him through that experience
a small dose of mushrooms a long while
ago I saw a version of me in the corner
and what I realized was that that boy
was worthy of love and if I could see
him struggling through loneliness at
school a lack of support from friends
it's just straight up loneliness I would
have told him that I was proud of him
for getting through the things that he's
got through you're working hard you're
worthy of acceptance and love you don't
need to offer the world any in order for
it to love you back it's hard to be
someone that thinks about things deeply
because there is a in-kind Association
of suffering that comes along with that
it's about a blessing and a curse to
fill things so very deep but I think
that the price is worth it I think that
the depth of enjoyment that you get out
of life is worth it and for that young
boy that I saw that was sat on the
ground that was alone I'd have picked
him up and killed him and said you're
doing great